my YouTube video right now my subtitles
have nothing to do with what I'm saying
like for instance if if I'm saying
and like you know like hi everyone my
subtitles would be like today's the
worst day of my life
hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast I'm
your host Joey and I'm with the boys as
per usual and I have a special guest
sitting next to me please introduce
yourself
I've never been laughed at after asking
that question the way that Sally just
looked over at you being like
what the hell did he just say
got here three minutes ago
[Applause]
I appreciate you being so accommodating
yeah thank you so much for coming on by
the way yeah thank you for having me hi
everyone I'm Sally omaki um an idol and
voice actor here in Japan thank you so
much take care thank you so much for
coming on because we've tried to get you
on like so many times right we have
mutual friends yeah yeah I hear from
them
so I go talk to my manager about it and
she doesn't reply to me so
like so many times we miss Sally that I
just thought she didn't exist for a
while like I was just like who is very
very uh popular request people were like
we'd love it yeah
unique perspective thank you so do you
want to maybe just do a quick run
through of like what you do for people
who might not know who you are
um I'm in a Japanese voice acting Idol
group called
so we have like a character
um that's an idol but we also the voice
actor is also work as an idol as well
and I don't know I guess I also do a lot
of uh I'm seeing okay yeah a lot of
events not good at public speaking
though so
it's okay nor am I and I don't know how
I found myself in this job either
because I've always been [__] of public
speaking until uh kind of like trial by
fire you put they put you on a stage and
you're like I don't know what I'm doing
but I'm just going to pretend and wait
but that makes more sense for you
because you're a YouTuber right Clayton
you're an idol yeah like isn't isn't the
main job to be on stage I'm an idol by
mistake though
yeah how did that happen so I came to
Japan
um to become a voice actor and I
couldn't really read um that much
Japanese so for the
auditioning I didn't really read like
the information but I saw characters so
I was like okay so it's a voice acting
group right and then I got in and then
they were like well you're gonna be an
idol too and like oh okay and then
you've got bathing to being an idol
you basically went for a job interview
and you're like I don't know what the
job is but yeah I see a cute anime girl
so I'm gonna fight I mean I should have
known though because by the third round
like usually in voice acting auditions
people would be doing like vocal
warm-ups yeah everybody was fixing their
makeup so I'm like I should like that's
when I should have known
yeah there was a dancing part too and
I'm like I don't know why you guys need
to see me dance
I'm like okay weird but okay I'm gonna
go even further back that's okay
so why did you originally grow up and
then how did that how did that go from
because it's a big leap to be like I
want to go to Japan and be a voice
actors like that's a huge thing oh yeah
um I was born and raised in Los Angeles
all my life up until like seven years
ago okay
right right and
um I wasn't really into anime when I was
really young you know right but uh in
middle school I met Gintama
oh
and like before then
um I went to like a school where there
weren't many Asian people around me so
like this is a really bad thing to say
but I was kind of ashamed of being
Japanese you know I was like why am I
not like the other people you know like
bringing you know it's like really
typical story but you know you bring
your Japanese school lunch and
everybody's like ew what is that you
know I feel that yeah yeah so I was like
why am I not like other girls and like
you know I pretended like I couldn't
speak Japanese in front of my parents oh
wow so yeah I was like shutting every
Japanese aspect in my life like out but
I met Gintama and yeah Gintama and I got
into the anime culture and it finally
made me like really like who I was right
you know like embrace the Japanese side
right yeah culture yeah it's insane that
you say that because you know you're
saying you grew up in La which is now
like if I would think of city that is
like the biggest cultural Melting Pot
I've been to in the world it's probably
La you know L.A is so many different
cultures and you know has it changed
over like the years where you've grown
up in La where now
it's like more accepted to be every kind
of like different culture and ethnicity
I heard with um covid and everything
like uh anime became pretty mainstream
and very very popular so yeah it
definitely had an explosion of the
coverage I think like it changed a bit
in that way yeah because I actually like
I think I went through something similar
because I grew up in Brighton and I was
also I think like the only Asian kid in
my school the same yeah same same for
you as well yeah and now like Brighton
is like the super Progressive City with
so many like different cultures and I
look at my city now and I'm like I do
not recognize the city that I grew up in
that yeah what was like because you know
you're from La what was like little Toca
like when you were growing I was like
was that even like a thing at all it was
a thing while I was there
um you know people would have a little
Meetup with their cosplay community and
stuff I was there too oh hell yeah
dressing up as like attacking Titan nice
yeah and then like we would be all
bloody and people would give us weird
scares me like why are there bloody
teenagers they're just like holding the
cops I think there's been a crime
because you guys have been in Japan for
around the same time right seven years
yeah I moved about seven years ago as
well oh yeah yeah back in like 2016
something like that yeah so I feel like
we and weirdly enough like you know with
you it's America but for me it's
Australia like I feel like we it sounds
like we had very similar kind of
upbringings in that sense because like I
also had like a period as well where
like you know because being half
Japanese and a predominantly you know
white country like Australia even with
all of like the different nationalities
and everything I definitely felt like a
bit of like a weird cultural identity
crisis almost where it's like I was the
only Asian kid in my school I got
bullied for it uh to an extent and so I
was kind of like not ashamed but I guess
like I wasn't like upfront as much yeah
right about like being Japanese which
like I think you know my mom didn't
really take that all too well you know
she was like no you should be proud to
be Japanese you know and everything like
that and I don't think for me it was
Gintama but it was like it was something
else I'm some other anime but yeah was a
great choice which is which is insane
because you know when we went to visit
Sydney I was like oh that's a lot of
Asian people there's so many Asians
like Sydney especially because I think
it's like the biggest Japanese like uh
like group in all of Australia as well
there's a huge Japanese community in
Australia now
um but I feel yeah that definitely
changed over time I don't know what it
was maybe it was okay here's a big test
right was it easy you guys to find like
good Japanese food when you were like
growing up in LA or Australia
um because uh now you know now us
visiting there I think it's pretty easy
to find good Japanese food especially in
La was it like the same way when you
guys were growing up well um because my
parents were born and raised in Japan
right we wouldn't really go out to eat
Japanese food I know what that was like
yeah we had the benefit of having
Japanese
I just thought that makes sense right
yeah I was going for like a roast dinner
yeah no no it's like the same yeah it's
like the like same for me as well except
like you know if I wanted to show my
friends like Thai food they'd be like oh
is there I don't think like Thai food
restaurants was like even really a
concept because we got like one Thai
restaurant that I knew of and it was
mine I thought it was like my parents so
yeah but you could use that as the hook
right like to your friends with me like
I know this bomb ass Thai place and they
just invite them to your house yeah if
you've never told that story you could
just lie to everyone and this is the
best Thai restaurant yeah yeah yeah that
was back in the day when you know you
take your friends to try a new Cuisine
and like what do you mean you eat rice
with everything like you fancy
[__]
what is that okay so I want to ask
questions again Tama why was it Gintama
that God you want anime well um it was
just a moment in my life where I was
just like hitting rock bottom yeah and
um you know there was just a moment in
my life when I wasn't really laughing at
anything and I was in my room skipping a
lot of like school days and stuff just
because I didn't want to go to school
and I was on Tumblr and this like Google
and this like collage like just came
around and I was like what is this like
like it was like a really stupid joke
that was like really funny you know and
I feel like that kind of joke was
something that I needed in my life you
know like something I can kind of laugh
at like being like like what is this you
know I started watching it and then I
started listening to sugita tomokaza
radio yeah and I uh found out like that
you could pursue a career in voice
acting and that's where it kind of got
me and you were just like [__] it I'm
going to Japan yeah I'm just gonna
figure it out yeah well um before I came
to Japan
um my cousin's friend who lived in Japan
also wanted to become a voice actor and
so we went to a voice acting school over
the summer for like one day like a trial
day and I thought you could only pursue
voice acting as an adult because every
single time I would search like
Wikipedia for a voice actor's name
they'd be like oh I started at 18 or I
started after college so I thought it
was like an adult thing but when I went
to the voice acting school in Japan like
the girls in that class were like sorry
sorry about that
so I went to the voice acting school in
Japan the girls in that class were like
16 17. they were like my age so I was
like
you could be that young and like start
and you know I felt kind of rushed I was
like I'm already you know Behind These
Girls so I need to go
now where are you late
so yeah so like what was there like a
specific point where you were like okay
I really really want to pursue voice I
think or was it just kind of like hey
this seems like kind of like a thing a
fun thing I can try to pursue yeah was
it something you always wanted to do as
like a a child yeah from a young age oh
no it was I basically never really had a
dream
um like it's I don't want to make this a
really dark story
please yeah you know when you're just
experiencing something like really bad
if when you
know that there is an end to it like it
just you know gets better like if you
have a class presentation you're like
it's okay it'll be over in like an hour
so yeah you know my nerves will be over
here for a while yeah so like somewhere
in middle school I was like you know
what my life is going to end at 18. I
was like I just I just you know I was
like this whatever I'm feeling right now
like it's okay like I'm gonna it's all
gonna be over by 18. so I'm just you
know gonna live until 18 and then I
never really had a dream or anything but
I met anime and when I was like 15 I was
like oh maybe like voice acting is
something that I want to do and you know
it really made me a better person like
anime really made me into a more happy
and like better person so like I kind of
want to be somebody that can do that for
people who are struggling as well so it
was the one and only dream like still to
this day that I have so awesome
yeah you know everybody's like what's
the meaning of life you know like why
are we living my meaning of life is like
well you know I still haven't seen the
last episode of One Piece or like you
know the manga that I started reading
like I haven't it's not done yet so yeah
I gotta live until then
hell yeah
that's an awesome story because I I
guess like I mean I mean
in the period I was growing up in the
like on the Internet it's like it was
almost like frowned upon to be like yo
anime is like important to me and has
done something important to me but I
think for like a lot of people out there
even though even if they don't like want
to admit it I mean for me personally
it's played like a huge influence my
life and has definitely like helped me
through some tough times as well
um so I think you know that's an awesome
and inspiring story for like a lot of
people to hear that it's not [__] you
know it it is uh it is just fiction but
it can have a real tangible real life
effect on people definitely yeah it
makes me curious though because you you
talked about your childhood and like you
kind of like
kind of always like pushed away the
Japanese side of you to kind of like fit
in better how like how much were you in
touch with your Japanese side when it
was like not around friends when you
were just like at home with your parents
um I would talk like half in English and
half in Japanese and I would always call
my grandma we have a really good
relationship with my grandma so but
those were the only times I usually
spoke in Japanese like my brother and I
would always speak in English so um
still to this day my brother has like an
American accent when he speaks in
Japanese right so it wasn't all that
much it was like 20 of my okay it was
Japanese yeah right was it was it kind
of hard to adjust and then be like all
right now everything's gonna be Japanese
and I can fully change everything my
lifestyle when I first came here
especially because well you know my
parents are Japanese so I look Japanese
so people expect me to speak perfect
Japanese all right but I'm here with
like kind of broken Japanese
you guys are in like a very similar yet
opposite situation because Joey is
obviously very very very good at
Japanese yeah obviously hafu so I think
you both have very like interesting
parallel stories yeah definitely yeah
there's a lot of aspects of your story
that I very much relate to
um but almost in like yeah it's kind of
said like in almost like an opposite
perspective or I guess like an opposite
upbringing almost but um you know I
think like one thing that's really
interesting is like you know you you
watch Gintama and you know you saw like
oh you know this is something that I
finally want to do and then the fact
that you went and [__] achieved that
is like insane you know that's like
that's so [__] awesome and like you
know I guess like now that you are kind
of you know in this like dream position
that you put yourself in now like do you
now have like a brand new goal that you
want to achieve in terms of like like
you know I'm sure as any games I'm a fan
would relate uh you know meeting Suite
one day would be that's a dream of mine
I met him oh you met him oh let's go she
gave me a birthday presentation I
brought it today oh [__] I don't know
where my man it was in my little makeup
bag it's like my good luck charm now
such a wholesome yeah hell yeah we got
we got the good ending guys I mean how
was meeting someone calls it like it was
amazing well um first of all you know
when people go into the entertainment
industry they expect so much like they
expect glamor so oh thank you so much
I'm sorry there you go I'm sorry
it's like a little keychain oh cute yeah
so I use it as like a good luck charm
but yeah
I think it's like a necktie but yeah
yeah you gave it to me this year so
whenever I go into auditions like I have
this but it makes so much sound the last
time I was in the studio
please stop making noise yeah no I was
in the studio doing a tape recording and
my manager was like that's making too
much noise like you need to take that
off because I was having it right here
like no you don't understand what this
is
like can you
do that why like it makes too much noise
can you swap to a T-shirt oh I don't
even think about that yeah I didn't know
how quiet you had to be
silent yeah yeah you really hear all
those mouth noises you made clearly
you're like oh you drink water please
do you wanna you wanna put it away
this in Focus blew me out
how was the process of kind of you like
you mentioned that you said your
Japanese wasn't as good how was it kind
of almost relearning all of that and
getting it to a point where you had to
be like kind of native oh well I
fully memorized like two episodes of
Gintama
like every single word yeah for the
first two episodes like I wrote it down
and that's impressive considering how
dialogue heavy Gintama is especially you
should re-watch the same movie over and
over again actually I did that yeah it
was actually a really good textbook
because there's so many like
um ways of speaking you know like
so and like the characters are really
distinct so it's like okay so people who
act like this like they say what does
she and people who act like this they
say like it's really like it really
helped me a lot and I would also
um watch the news programs and because
you know their intonation and their
pronunciation is like perfect yeah yeah
so
um I would basically just listen and
like say what they were saying yeah yeah
I mean I think like input is like one of
the most important things when it comes
to Japanese learning
um yeah when like how I got my listening
skills up was like very similar I it
turned out to be like dress up darling
um that I that I chose for some reason
uh just because I wonder why okay wait
wait hold on let me let me continue
uh just because like I thought in terms
like the genre of anime I think like
high school romance is kind of like at a
level where it's like much more
comprehensible for someone just starting
to like get to learn Japanese because I
look at my list I try listening to
[__] isekai or light novel
adaptations impossible I I I cannot even
comprehend half the stuff yeah because
like half the essay guys just like make
up words
yeah Japanese people like so why is it
written in kanji but it's like a German
word like how does that make any sense
yeah so I was like huh uh I think like
going for like a high school kind of
romance is the best way to go about it
for something that's like beginner level
for me yeah and dress-up darling just
happened to be airing at that time and I
just like chose an episode and I watched
to re-watch it like about 20 times damn
um I know like like honestly that really
really helps at least my listening
skills how did you get your listening
skills up
I don't think it's dress-up dog
I don't know really I just I guess just
existing around here
I've been forced to like hear it all the
time and yeah yeah and the way I view it
is like it's like building a like a
bridge made of Legos but you can only
put like one block down at your feet
each time right you can only pick up and
build the connections and use muscle
memory yeah I've still got a long way to
go and also I think when you learn a
language in the way that I think we
probably learned it I feel like you do a
lot of lazy things where like sometimes
I won't listen to the full sentence I'm
waiting for you to say keywords so I can
like like this this with this context I
understand what you're saying yeah yeah
which is like a bad habit which I need
to get out of because sometimes I'll
just listen to the sentence you'll be
like oh he said uh it's hot but he said
like five he said like a bunch of
different things around it which I
didn't really pay much attention I mean
I feel sometimes I do that that's what I
do it too yeah I think that's just like
a natural progression you go through
where it's like I can't be like you know
maybe like it helps you understand the
surrounding words more but it's yeah
it's all a slow process I think
consciously you're trying to listen to
every single word that makes up the
sentence but subconsciously you're like
oh he said hot and today so he must be
just talking about the weather you know
it just feel like you're like I'm like a
game show where you're listening to a
question and you're just waiting for
like some key part of the question to be
answered so yeah yeah I got it it's kind
of like yeah yeah did you did you have
to learn kanji at all yes like I mean I
still can't read that much kanji which
was a problem for me actually this year
when I was hosting the Crunchyroll anime
Awards I saw that oh yeah yeah
what is your favorite people's name
people's names but also um the script
was really long but I got the script
like a day or like two days before but
um usually for like aof 2020 like for
this year like every year we would have
the script right in front of us right so
um I could write like how to read the
sanjays yeah but for countryable they
wanted to make it like an American award
show so you couldn't have the script in
front of you like there was a prompter
in front of you so I couldn't write like
what the kanji like meant or like how to
read it but I literally got the script
last night so I'm like I don't know how
to read that
and also I'm like my eyesight is really
bad so like usually the words would be
like this small but I had to like have
them
that's really bad for a telephone
yeah and it wasn't like the sentences
were like all broken into like lines
because I had to make it that big it
doesn't imagine it's like and the award
goes to
uh yeah
there was a moment where it was like
or something like that where it was like
you know it was like really popular all
over the world but I just remembered
that you know like the kin part while
doing the script but like during the
actual War show I didn't know how to
read it so I said
which is like yeah it got discovered
you're not wrong yeah
yeah but yeah so people who already knew
this group was like oh my gosh there's
all the stuff yeah I saw there was a
moment on the award show where like your
contact lens or something fell out
as well just add like insult on like
yeah like everything you had to like
juggle at the same time I couldn't sleep
for like two weeks after that
because during the streaming I just
can't hear it but people the second my
contacts fell out and I looked like
behind me to fix it yeah yeah you can
hear the crowd being like
oh [__] and that voice haunted me that's
what I hear in my mind yeah yes it
haunted me and you know I was like I'm
probably never gonna be invited back so
like whatever I'm just you know I'm just
gonna like Wing It excuse me you handed
it like a professional one yeah but the
way you handled it just I I was just
like nah I'm all right this is this is a
professional I should be taking notes I
don't think there's many other people
they can ask
a handful of people they could ask yeah
I went I went um backstage after that
and I was crying into my management like
I can't but they were like you need to
go back in five minutes
shut up go back out but I can't even
read the script
God damn yeah as long as uh people watch
and uh that's all
[Music]
live promotion stuff with um working on
more of the Japanese side because they
always want a script yeah and we're like
no no we are and we don't do that yeah
and I'll be like you tell me what to say
and I'll put it in naturally they're
like what if you say something bad I'm
like why would it say something bad I
know what I'm doing it's like I don't
know what I'm like
yeah yeah there's always just kind of
that worry that like we just want to
know exactly what you're going to say
yeah it's live you know yeah but it's
also that you know ironic thing of like
you know they prepare like these like
insanely long scripts and then I've been
in situations where it's like you know a
five to ten page script for something
right and it's like uh yeah so we just
finished and we only actually read like
three of these Pages
you'll give them sometimes they ask for
a script or they want the rough it
you'll say and you'll send it to them
and then on the day just when you're
reading it you're like ah this isn't the
vibe I'm just gonna change it yeah live
yeah yeah normally everyone's always
happy it's like you know I think you is
the MC you normally
doing and you can be like I think this
is a better idea yeah like uh out of all
like the live shows and like events I've
done with Japanese companies what the
vibe I get is that they want everything
to go on script word for words before
the event happens yeah and then the
event happens and you turn up and you're
like uh so is it okay if I just get the
gist of it and everyone's like yeah yeah
sure because there's no way you can
memorize because I feel bad for these
script right
it starts to memorize like 10 like
you've mentioned like 10 pages yeah
if you gave me five years yeah I could
barely memorize my own birthday yeah
it's not gonna happen yeah I'll figure
it out but for me though because I'm so
bad at public speaking that kind of
helps me yeah
they don't know they don't want to
assume that you're comfortable always
being able to just be like yeah I'll do
it yeah I suppose it's your voice acting
experience has played into that as well
because I mean that's where you
definitely have a script that you have
to read off of that can't be changed
this episode is sponsored by gamer Subs
Gamers sugar is a thing of the past if
you need a clean energy drink with no
crashes no sugar and tastes amazing you
better best be drinking some games
exactly what I need I just came back
from a trip to America guys and I've
been eating and drinking nothing but
sugar please I need something else in my
life well you Americans and God will be
happy to know that gamer Subs is zero
calorie Energy Formula it is keto and
diabetic friendly as well with a
guilt-free health energy that you can
drink throughout the day that keeps you
calm but alert but Joey I already have
plenty of energy in my life sometimes
I'm not like Connor I don't need to take
17 shots of espresso well lucky for you
gone gamer Subs now comes
feel free you can get a caffeine free
they also have these amazing waifu cups
and I refuse to suck on anything else
starting on the 1st of September every
cup is a limited edition and never
printed again what are you waiting for
go to the link in the description down
below to get your waifu cups and get
your free samples today gamestops.gg
trash taste and make sure to use our
code trash taste that's
g-a-m-e-r-s-u-p-p-s dot GG slash trash
taste back to the episode so if you're a
voice actor and an idol yeah right is
that like a percentage of which side you
tend to do more or is it like yeah who
voice acts or am I a voice yeah when
people ask you what you do do you say
voice actor or Idol I say voice actor
just because I want to be a voice
sometimes when um like in situations you
know when you know saying an idol would
work better you know like if I screw up
so badly
as a voice actor somewhere I'm gonna be
like I'm sorry
actually yeah I'm sorry
like sometimes I would pull the idle
card like during like my um I also do
have a YouTube channel yeah right like
for the title like you know
um I use Idol and voice actor depending
on like which one would be funnier you
know in the context you know so you
didn't know you're going to be an idol
you passed the audition yeah like you're
an idol and you're like oh God what do I
what happened was this the first
audition that you did no I took a lot of
voice acting auditions but I failed a
lot of them because I usually um make it
to the final stage with my English but
during the final stage they would
usually give you a script and they're
like look at it for 30 seconds and read
it and I'm like okay well I could look
at it but I can't read it
yeah you could give me an hour I
wouldn't know how to read this
yeah but it was also a problem when I
first went into voice acting school oh
my gosh yeah this has never happened
what's up there's something wrong with
our uh
I think it's overheating
yeah when I the voice acting school that
I went to
um for you to get in there was a written
test as well which I didn't know oh yeah
and what's on this written test like uh
it's to see if you could if you know
basic Japanese you know because there's
you know there's a lot of people who
want to be voice actors but they're like
you know like we need you to have like
basic language I couldn't read a thing
I'm just sweating yeah I'm like oh no so
I took out a red pen and I wrote I'm
sorry I'm from America
I can't imagine that went well but like
right after that there was also like an
acting test too so my pronunciation was
like okay so like you know even if I
couldn't read or write you know I was
like I could like speak you know well so
that just sounds like every exam
experience I've had I'm just like oh I
can't do this section but I'm gonna try
and Ace this section okay this section
carries me for the section that I'm that
I suck at yeah how many schools did you
go to because I actually did a video
filming at one of the schools and it was
one of the most embarrassing experiences
of my life because I had to voice act in
Japanese in front of people who were
doing this seriously yeah they were all
very kind about it they all came
basically just to film this video that I
was making yeah I felt so bad there to
sit there and listen to me butcher the
language
um but like there was like one thing I
found really interesting is that it
wasn't like you it's not just one voice
acting school that's like you'd have to
work your way up the different tiers of
voice acting yeah right the one that I
filmed at was like a an agency had would
select you to join it and you were in
like kind of like the upper echelon of
of the like
um trainees wanting to get into voice
acting it's like a weird like casting
a beginner class okay okay
because I had no acting skills but also
my Japanese sucks that had every reason
to be in the beginning do a lot of
people progress that's one thing that I
didn't really get to ask them or learn
about so I didn't know the rate of like
progression the very people who would
drop out I
I mean I know by the time um I was only
there at that school for like six months
because I got into the this
in like six months so
um but by those like months already half
the class was basically gone you know
okay yeah so a lot of dropouts for a lot
of people that just yeah a lot of people
dropped out image is just expensive as
well right yeah it's really expensive
but like uh the one that I went to was
like one of the cheaper ones yeah okay
yeah but I was so I was put in the
beginner class but on day one there was
a girl that was fluent in French I was
like damn I was gonna pull my English
card
like this is how I was gonna get into
this agency but this girl who knows
perfect Japanese she's so pretty she has
a beautiful voice and she speaks perfect
French what an [__] I can't do this
right now
I see this as a negative yeah
so yes but this is the beginner class
and I'm like you know if I can't be the
first in this beginner's class like
there's no way I'm gonna get into the
agency yeah you're like I gotta be the
best in the beginner class yes and it's
like if I can't be like the best here
like even if some miracle happens and I
get into an agency there's no way I can
compete against my seniors who are
already so good at it so then I started
going to a different like school who
taught you privately yeah right and um
that the principle at that teacher was
the one who actually introduced me to
none of them like the audition okay so
so he also thought this group was a
voice acting group
nobody had a question
everyone
is really good at dancing and pretty
maybe yeah
no the dancing part oh my god there was
the audition process was so stressful
because
um for none of the Nunes you need you
ever dance before I did figure I did
competitive figure skating oh okay wait
wait hold on the can of worms in L.A
but yeah but you know figure skating and
just ballet and there's like slow
Movement Dance things it's just so
different from Idol dancing so but like
when I first got the Callback to be in
the third stage of this audition it was
two days before the third stage and they
were like you need to memorize this
dance like this so-and-so groups dance
but they didn't have like a video sent
to me okay so they were like just look
for it online so they gave you a
transcript be like
so the right leg goes off wow that's the
source look it up but like they gave me
the title so I looked it up there's only
you know how they're really strict with
copyright so yeah so I see the music
video but first of all it's the short
version so second of all it's a music
video so there's barely any dancing like
it's like lip sync of these pretty girls
and like what do you want me to learn
yeah so I went to this the audition not
knowing any of the choreography yeah
right and the girl that sat next to me
luckily she's my uh you know
future member as well yeah but she was
like do you want to go practice the
dance in the hallway I was like for
yesterday
but I didn't want to be like because I
didn't I don't know the choreography
because I don't want to you know
so I'll let you take the leader yeah I
was literally like how about we watch
each other dance and like give each
other like constructive criticism you go
first
and so she would dance in front of me
and I'm like how about you you know
where that looked yeah
but she was like but I just you know she
knew that I was from America and my uh
cousin was a dancer so I borrowed her
clothes so I looked like a dancer
I knew what I was talking about so I was
like you should do the movements really
slowly because you know dance is just a
lot of poses put together so you should
just like do it more slowly here I'll do
it with you so she's like she's like
doing it through the steps
he's just like violently staring just
trying to remember everything is like do
that part again just one more time
please yeah yeah so then but then once I
memorize it I'm like I think we're good
we should go back
and I will now Ace this exam you and
then it was you know the time for the
Dancehall Edition you know all these
like different groups we were put in
different groups
and while we were dancing I saw that one
of the judges had a video camera
um going around filming us it was
obvious he wasn't filming us dancing it
was like my face right so I was like
they don't care about the dance it's
about the charisma
so I was like you know what I'm gonna
wink at the judges
so yeah no everybody else is like
dancing really seriously and you know I
just learned danzo halfway through I
forget it yeah I don't have any like
dance just like just just just cut you
just fill me up here just don't film any
of my body because I'm not moving out I
don't know what I'm doing I don't know
what I'm doing this sounds like an
entire anime this literally sounds like
the Naruto test they did well like an
example
the dancing was the red herring they
didn't care about the dogs you know did
the plot armor
that's crazy I watched enough animated
no yeah yeah it's like I know your
scheme
that's crazy
somehow worked at which point did you
find out that uh you were auditioning
for an idol group
um well once I got in and
yeah once I got
people will just audition for [__] they
don't know what it is yeah they don't
know yeah like once I got in and they
started caring about uh my weight and
stuff I was like why would you care
about my weight you know like you know
wait how does that conversation go are
they like hey what is that is that like
a granola bar how many carbs so
um you know everybody like a majority of
the members were teenagers so my parents
had to come in for a meeting before you
know signing the contract and right then
and there they told me they were like
you should probably lose like 10
kilograms jeez but the thing was I wrote
um on my resume oh should I stop talking
yeah that's very loud
so many distractions very unfortunate
yeah so I I lied on my resume saying
like I was 10 kilograms lighter
do you feel that they would just
arbitrarily picking a number that they
were like this is thin like yeah because
it's really different you know like
muscle mass and everything so they're
like you don't know what you're talking
about yeah so I would go I'll have you
know my BMI is perfectly normal actually
yeah I do like that throughout this
entire thing you've been like pushing
back in your own way against every
single like yeah yeah like almost
unnecessarily stereotypical thing
they've been asking for yeah no I'm not
gonna do that I've somehow successfully
Uno reverse caught every conversation
yeah why did it worked yeah it worked I
mean I mean I guess it didn't work
because they told me to lose them
yeah I mean it worked during the resume
part but like I guess they were like you
know you're lying kind of thing but yeah
did you lose 10 no okay
well the thing was that meeting was
during winter and I was wearing like my
mom's coat that was this big
yeah right so during the summer next
like the next summer like you know um I
have like a fairly skinny waist because
with like figure skating and everything
so like I got a lot of fat on my face so
like during the summer I would wear like
a really tight clothes and be like since
last winter I lost 10 kilograms I just
took the code off damn she did it oh my
God sorry I don't know why this is the
first time it's ever happened do you
think it's overheating yeah it's most
definitely is do we have a fan in the
office sure it has a fan built in I
don't know why it's not built it okay
can we get some do you have any ice or
cold stuff that we can put it on yeah
maybe
all right sorry about that this has
never happened before of course yeah
right
um okay so you got in Lost okay so so
how did they explain to you that you
were going to be part of an idol group
was that part of the conversation when
the contracts were being signed they
never really like explained it explained
it it was more like
um the more interviews you do with like
all these magazines and the way the
staff members would explain to you how
you should explain the group they always
use the word like idle group and I'm
like where's the voice acting part of it
kind of sounds to me like uh they didn't
really say anything until you like you
got on stage you kind of realized what
the what the hell am I doing here this
is like a new concept as well like Idol
super voice actors this is like a first
of its kind or um I mean there was like
of course love live and stuff but I
think it was the first time you know a
producer for a lot of idol groups The
Godfather okay it was the first time he
produced an idol group like voice actor
and Idol group so I think that's why the
idol part is really strong he's the guy
who created like akb48
consider like the Godfather of the idol
world yeah okay what was the what was
the first gig you had when you like was
it like a it must have been a shock just
the first time actually having to do
Idol stuff it was just a lot of dance
lessons like it was like two days of
dance lessons and like two hours of
voice acting lessons
a bit off
he's going could you just wrap ice onto
it yeah okay okay sorry
oh
um show like we swap so that
like when that switches off since it's
over here I mean it's still gonna look
weird okay we can just make a note of it
that we just keep turning it on I think
this episode is sponsored by Harrys
listen I have been using Harry's
exclusively for my shaving for the past
two or three years now don't believe me
let me go and grab it
this bad boy is the Harry's razor and I
don't go anywhere without it I'm super
lazy I'm sure all of you know that and I
don't want to change the blades as much
as possible and Harry's my god do these
blades last I I feel like I get like two
or three times more shaves out of this
blade than other blades before they
start to feel dull it's also very
affordable that's why whenever I travel
abroad to countries that actually sell
hydrogen store I buy a bunch of these to
bring that with me and you can
experience that latest and greatest in
Harry's Razer lineup delivered straight
to your door for just ten dollars at
harrys.com trash taste it's nice to have
a razor that feels like it treats my
face the way it deserves and they're
still offering a no risk trial don't
like your shave no worries it's all mam
games plus you can also schedule
replacement blade delivery whenever you
need them with refills as low as two
dollars and you can experience their
sleekest handle yet with their craft
handle style set for just ten dollars
value to 17 so what are you waiting for
elevate your shave with the latest and
greatest in Harry's razor handle lineup
today get your 17 craft handle starter
set for just ten dollars at harris.com
trash taste that's how harrys.com trash
taste back to the episode uh your first
your first concerts yeah so what was
that like our first concert
um oh gosh I feel really bad for saying
this like uh we had a meeting with our
boss and our boss was like you're always
gonna remember your first concert
because like this is a life-changing
experience that sounds really
threatening
you'll remember this but I think it's
gonna be such a magical moment sure I
was so nervous I don't remember a single
thing so every single time like every
anniversary that our group has we always
have this interview where it's like you
know you like look back at your past and
be like what do you remember you're not
your first concert I'm like I don't
remember a single thing that was so
nervous
I don't remember anything but um our
first live actually sprained my ankle oh
[__] yeah it was like an open rehearsal
where people could watch on the first uh
number I fell oh [__] sprained my ankle
oh my God so um that part I remember but
everything else I don't
wait so how many did you have to
continue with the rest of the rehearsals
yeah I didn't even know how bad it was
sprained but like the next day I went to
the doctors and they gave me crutches
the adrenaline and everything got me
going yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
but my uh it was my left leg but it was
already kind of screwed up with um
figure skating for so long yeah so
that's one thing I wanted to get into
like how did you get into the figure
skating thing figure skating there was
this Japanese Drama called
um
and my dad was so into it right and he
was like do you want to go figure
skating tomorrow like this the next day
he saw in it yeah so we went and
apparently I was really good like I got
scouted by the coach
so I started but then again the problem
was I was so bad at like you know the
public eye it just wasn't my thing so
the reason I quit was because
um I had a panic attack after my short
program
my last competition I was like this
thing is just not for me so like because
that happened still to this day I don't
know how I'm an idol still I'm
performing it yeah it sounds like this
is the worst line yeah it's it's funny
because it's like considering how
nervous you are on stage and how as you
say you're not good on stage like you've
managed to find yourself in situations
where you have to perform on stage yeah
you know so I pretend that when I'm in
Idol I just pretend that I'm an
undercover spy
anyway so explain the thought process of
that so you know like as somebody who
wanted to be a voice like a voice actor
only yeah and you know who didn't really
want to perform on stage if you think
that you're a spy you know and you're
like I'm only doing this like this isn't
my job like I'm only here to know what
happens behind closed doors you know so
I can experience what like other people
can't see you know even the
documentaries won't show you
I feel really cool while doing it
you are literally the definition of fake
it yeah that's crazy that is that is
impressive how long between like you you
know you getting the audition uh was
there between like doing your first live
and Performing for the first time
only like six months it was even before
we debuted we had our first live so yeah
it really wasn't that long okay so after
this first performance did you just like
have fans right away
um yes because
the producer was of course so people
yeah and you know Sony music
it was overwhelming I was like people
who like me that's a first I'm not used
to that there's even like fans uh
Japanese fans as well right it must be
so bizarre thinking like damn I I just
showed up here and I yeah you guys like
me yeah but like I felt really happy
because again my goal was to be somebody
like sugita Tomoka as it was to me you
know so I felt really happy when people
were like you motivated me to pursue my
dream as well you know like you make me
really happy but that makes me really
happy as well
I'm curious like what the training
process for an idol is you said there
was like six months like what is the
process between you becoming the eye are
you becoming an idol and you know doing
your life
well because majority of our members
were still in school and ha almost half
weren't even from Tokyo so we only had
lessons during Saturday and Sunday okay
and it was like the full day we would
have dance practice and also voice
acting lessons as well and singing
lessons and we would have like acting
tests on Christmas day yeah
um
happy Christmas
have a drumstick recite the entirety of
Pulp Fiction right now yeah but but I
mean I guess because we had an upcoming
anime coming up and um we also had
characters but
those characters weren't really official
yet right right you know so we had to
have like a lot of acting tests to see
like who would fit which character so
everybody was like really serious about
it but I was like really on Christmas
day enjoy you guys have families
Christmas isn't that big of a thing
right sorry yeah so especially yeah
we would have really stressful acting
tests and they would give you like a
report card what does an acting test
look like in Japan so um for our group
it was reciting literally
it's like a tongue twister in Japan like
a lot of voice actors do it in voices
I saw them all practicing tongue
twisters it's like a 10 minute tongue
twister it's really really long yeah I
just wouldn't associate your quality to
act with your ability to do a tongue
twister I just feel like that's I feel
like um especially in anime though like
tongue twisters are really important
yeah right
um especially if you have to like speak
fast and make the enunciation sound
perfect and natural as well like I think
tongue twisters is a great way of like
kind of practicing enunciation
especially yeah I could see how it's
practicing enunciation but I wouldn't in
my mind I wouldn't think that I would
want to be judged on my ability to act
based on if I did like red truck [__]
blue truck
do you mean red leather yellow leather
or like whatever this is like a bunch
you say like yeah so it seems so
arbitrary yeah you just kind of be like
no you can't act why uh well he failed
on the tongue he didn't say Peter Piper
probably uh yeah she's sold seashells
somewhere else and
I just feel like it'd be such an
arbitrary decision but I guess it makes
sense and the way you described it yeah
I just can't imagine it it was based on
like how loud your voice was as well
while you did those so when you have to
like shout it yeah because you know in
Japanese yeah like how you know how you
yeah right say things it's really
important I guess especially in the
voice acting industry so and you're like
your tongue twister and those things
were like just the basic things that you
had to be perfect at yeah my feeling is
the opposite problem when I was doing
more people were too loud
less is more what do you mean people
sometimes get they emote too much on
lines right they get two lines it's a
shouting line but you're not trying to
blow the mic out you're trying to shout
not not be Vault like there's a
difference between shouting and just
having a lot of volume yeah and those
two things are very different it's like
the way I'd like to subscribe it is like
you know sometimes your dad would shout
at you but he wasn't loud at you but you
knew you were a [__] yeah it's not like
that right it's like you he was shouting
and it depends on the dad right yeah the
intensity in my Dives the quieter he was
the more [__] I was in here exactly like
laying intensity without relying on
volume yeah yeah kind of a concept that
you have to I think as well there's like
an interesting I guess like cultural
difference with like Japanese I've seen
versus English acting whereas like you
know a lot of like say like Hollywood
movies you know there's a lot of like
scenes where it's very quiet and very
like you know expressive but in a very
like uh subtle way yeah you know like to
the point where like you'd watch like a
Matthew McConaughey movie and you'd be
like I actually can't make out what the
[__] he's saying because he's so quiet
and so mumbly whereas with a lot of like
Japanese stuff like not not just Anime
but like even live action stuff it's all
about like projecting it's more like a
stage play than like how you were doing
a movie right I mean I guess that's just
like what you describe is basically just
a lot of like anime voice acting which
is I guess more over the top yeah and a
motive than you would say get in a
Hollywood film because it's so weird
seeing live-action Japanese actors you
know in like a live-action TV drama
because sometimes I see the way they act
and I'm like they are not acting like
people they're acting like anime yeah
yeah yeah totally I think that's why one
of the most critically acclaimed films
came out of Japan's most recent memory
was um what was that one with the where
they were driving around a lot and
husband died or something it was I
forgot what it's called it was like it
was literally every day I guess because
it was way more of a subtle and way more
uh yeah a lot more toned down and more
realistic I forget what it's called I
think it was nominated for an Oscar I
think yeah well I I guess that like you
know this is going completely off topic
now but on the topic of this that's why
I've really enjoyed the voice acting of
B Stars yes because it will it felt way
more natural and way more it was almost
like live action you know they weren't
speaking over the top even if there were
some really intense scenes there it felt
way more like a western Hollywood film
in terms of like its approach to waxing
and this approach to like and then I
feel especially with B stars like when
that got translated to the English dub
as well I feel like the dark voice
actors just sounded so much more natural
than a lot of other like dubs that I've
heard because it's like the nature of
the show already with like you know the
fact that the whole thing was Mo capped
and the actors were actually Mo capped
while doing the lines and everything so
it's like it just felt more like oh I'm
actually like listening to people talk
rather than like anime characters in a
weird way I don't know yeah like out of
curiosity when you were doing the voice
acting school and the voice acting
training was there any kind of like
lessons or training in terms of like
actually getting into a character as
opposed to just kind of like emoting and
saying lines
um it was there was actually no acting
at all for the first couple of months
well I mean okay
did you have much of an acting
background in the States before never I
I took acting as an elective in middle
school for one trimester yeah I didn't
get a single line
I was just there
I was the bunny c
yeah so yeah did America go to Japan
there was like absolutely no way for me
to practice acting before I came here so
I would have to like make up my own ways
of practicing acting is very clicky in
the west at least when I was growing up
I wanted I remember I wanted to try and
do it and it was already the theater
kids were already well established who
the theater kids were yeah and I was
like you cannot
yeah I think that happens a lot but
um at least uh you're able to make it
work here
so so uh like you know you joined the
idol group were you like I guess ever
interested or had an interest in like
the idol culture of Japan before you
decided to join a lot I always loved
watching Idols you know like
just the hello project groups and stuff
I I loved them but it was like really
never a career option I didn't even
think I could be one you know so right I
didn't think I could be once it was
never a career option so yeah what do
you think the appeal of being an idol is
being an idol
because I'm just trying to imagine
because obviously our audience is very
Western and I think that uh a lot of
people's struggles really understand the
appeal of Idols in like kind of a
western like perspective and like we
don't really get it even though they
very much have their own version of it
in terms of the way that they do it in
Japan I think a lot of people they don't
really get it yeah I think when most
people in the west hear the word Idol
they think of like Japan or Korea yeah
you know or like some kind of Asian
country whereas like you know not to say
that like you know we had [__] people
we definitely have it it's just it's
like a different it's a different it's a
different Beast entirely even the K-pop
and J-pop that like I feel like it's so
different oh yes yeah absolutely I feel
like standards are very very different
yeah K-pop is more like when you debut
like you need to be perfect but in J-pop
it's more like they want people yeah
they want people that's not well
established and like they want
Yeah the more you look like a potato
yeah so that's why like a lot of people
say when you go into auditions you
should never dye your hair because like
it should you know be natural
because they just like want to see you
go from like a normal girl to like they
want to see you in the purest form are
they like dumb with you after you've
crushed it they're like I'm done I'm
gonna find someone else I hope not
but yeah that's nice okay like I'm
curious because you know especially in
like Idol culture I guess
marketability comes into a lot of plays
uh especially with the Japanese Auto
culture did you were you ever like
not like were you ever kind of like not
pressured but were you ever like kind of
like given a kind of like a niche or a
character to fulfill as your like public
stage
um well I mean they they didn't really
tell me to be like you know actively
cute and stuff like that but I mean they
would tell me to not cuss of course
you know they're like you know watch
your language and those kind of things
but um I feel like our group isn't
really as uh strict as strict you know
it's not like act like a certain way but
that's very like that's what you in a
lot of like Western media we get told a
lot of time from a journalism whatever
it's so tough It's so strict you didn't
have to do this you have to do an X and
it always seems like that but I mean
that's great to hear yeah
like rather than him producing you it's
more because there's so many girls yeah
it's like
how you can produce yourself you know it
makes sense she's like I'm not taking
care of all yeah
it's literally like we gave you the
chance you know like we gave you the
stage yeah so whoever can like Blossom
on their own like I mean that makes way
more sense than being like you should be
these characters yeah so that was
actually one of the reasons why I
started Twitter as well right right our
group um we weren't gonna have any
social media at first
but I was like don't you mean X actually
so yeah because like I was I was doing a
little bit of research on you and I saw
that like you know now you have quite
actually you know not only a large fan
base in Japan but also in a lot of
English-speaking countries as well
obviously because now everyone knows you
can speak English
um and I heard that one of the big
reasons why you got a big English fan
base is because you were memeing a
little bit on Twitter yeah you're you're
a little meme star on Twitter I really
um respected
you literally looked up to the biggest
memes
so you know I just wanted people I
didn't want to use like social media as
like advertisement I wanted it to be
something that would brighten somebody's
day you know like I wanted it to yeah so
uh because I think I discovered you
through either your Twitter your YouTube
um because there wasn't like you know
back back when you first became an idol
there weren't a lot of
I don't know if there are like any other
Idols that uh spoke English in a
Japanese idol group so kind of like you
I think for you you just bridge the gap
especially for Western audience to like
kind of like make it more approachable
um not to mention you had that like
almost personality Gap as well of like
you know in none of them you had you
know you were the idol girl right you
know playing you know playing the role
in the group and then meanwhile over on
Twitter you're like memes you know and I
think just like that almost like
disparity between the two personalities
was just like oh that's actually kind of
dope but like she can be an idol girl
but also be a memester
yeah I feel that's how it worked out but
like how did you like I guess you know
when you decided to start the Twitter
like and you started to like you know
post memes and you know just be you like
how did the that reception I guess like
come about well
um like I said you know a lot of idol
groups from is how you produce yourself
and when the first single came out I was
in the very third lane of the new single
and it was like it was pretty obvious I
was not the favorite the group speaker
and so I but um there's Politics on the
song yeah I mean like it would have been
fine if it was just me you know because
it's like you know like more people not
seeing me the better but it was my
character too like if I was in the third
line that means my character was also in
the very back and I didn't want that
like I wanted her to shine so I took
dancing lessons and
um I was so you know to get better at
dancing and then go to the front line
and then also I was like how should I
get more fans and I knew I didn't I
couldn't really make a lot of friends in
person but I had a lot of friends online
in America so I was like you know what
I'm probably better on the internet so
you know so I was like um I don't think
I can get a lot of fans during the live
so can I just like have my own like
internet sections yeah so yeah so yeah
that was one of the reasons why I
started I was like you know I can't
really show my personality in person
because I get so nervous but online it's
like total different yeah yeah it's like
it's easier to talk and everything so
right you said they like kind of
mentioned you know don't cost or
anything like that yeah how much Freedom
do you get with like the online stuff
and the online content that you do
um for Twitter it's literally you can
post anything you want I mean unless you
know it's like yeah yeah yeah stuff but
for my YouTube video
but for my YouTube videos
um I have to show my like staff members
first yeah that was one of the reasons
why um my YouTube video right now my
subtitles have nothing to do with what
I'm saying
um yeah
like for instance if if I'm saying
and like you know like hi everyone my
subtitles would be like today's the
worst day of my life
on purpose on purpose wait do you put
the subtitles
why do you do that you're such a villain
I love it I just really like dark humor
you know and it's just like
self-deprecating jokes is how I cope
with my life
but when I do it in Japanese like my
manager stops me like my whole entire
management team stops me being like stop
that's so get your brain that you can
keep the Western audience like amused of
what they love yeah yeah so the only way
I can the only way I can like go past
them is if I write it in English right
because like how are they gonna check
how are you gonna know what I'm saying
you are like absolutely like limit
testing like the eyes
like five heads right that's soaking
here
I want to start doing that but with
Japanese
just being like hey guys we're here
right now doing this video in Japanese
just like
for your tweets as well yeah for my
trees as well oh wait so you so you
tweet are both in Japanese and English
yeah so for the Japanese part they're
like
a heart emoji your English bite would be
like why did I wake up today
like the nightmare starts after I wake
up
they do but then when they they're like
why are you treating this I'm like
that's a mistranslation
you know like why are you believing like
it's hard in English
the joke's really hard to say in
Japanese like don't believe that holy
[__] you're like the hero of the
industry dude like you're just like
suboding everyone's expectations that's
crazy that's so funny okay now that I'm
hearing that I can totally see why you
know all the English speakers are like
this chick's life yeah if oceanoko had
this story I'd be way more interested
[Music]
this is so interesting this is so
fascinating every single like chance
you've had to like push it or not yeah
I'll try it yeah that's good have you
seen you know
[Music]
do you feel like it's uh how accurate
um I mean the part where like the very
first episode you know where the
producer is like oh because they're a
big like you know from this group like I
don't even know who they're I kind of
relate to that you know I feel like a
lot of people are like oh like welcome
welcome because of like the big agency
yeah yeah so and I kind of feel that as
well so I relate to it and I got scared
this episode of trash Chase is sponsored
by shipstation it's the Calm before the
holiday storm but you can prepare your
e-commerce business for the holiday rush
now just by using ship station whether
you're shipping from your house or a
warehouse shipstation can help increase
your profitability save time automating
your shipping and returns in the
shipstation dashboard and keep costs
down with industry leading career
discounts while your holiday orders just
keep keep rolling in with chip station
you get a free trial if you've been on
the fence and with ship station you get
some of the best shipping rates you can
find on the internet for a bunch of my
gums streamed over to ship stuff and
using shipstation just makes it way
easier and the shipping rates are
probably better than what you're used to
you can also quickly save and easily
update critical order information and
reduce errors you can effortlessly
integrate everywhere you sell online
including Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and
more and not just there because you can
also manage orders print labels compare
rates optimize every shipment and auto
delivery notifications you can get
discounts up to 84 off USPS and UPS
threads plus over 130 000 companies have
grown their e-commerce businesses with
shipstation set up your business for the
holiday season success with ship station
go to shipstation.com and use code trash
for a free 60-day trial that is
shiftstation.com code trash back to the
episode well like do you feel like okay
this is going on oceanic and you can
like stop me if I'm getting in too
intrusive but like do you feel like you
have like a public and Stage persona
versus like your personal life and how
do you balance that definitely
definitely but that
um also I feel like that goes for
anybody who's not even like in the
entertainment industry you know you have
a face when you're with your boss like
you're not gonna be like hey what's up
you know so I feel like
um uh like also I'm a people pleaser you
know I've been to people please yeah
so I feel like you know on stage like I
have to act a certain way that like
people want me to you know like I can't
be like I can't act that just because
I'm actually sad that day you know you
have to be like you know I'm gonna be
everybody's ray of sunshine and stuff
you know so I definitely think that
there is a gap between my personal life
and how I am on camera and usually that
Gap also kind of
is the reason I sometimes get sad and
just kind of have a mental breakdown
because people expect you to be this
like because of all the time be positive
and also be like super crazy because of
like the way I tweet and like but my
Japanese fans think I'm a big delinquent
because like I'm going against the
management so much but like reality is
like if like behind closed doors I'm not
like you know telling my managers what
to do and like you know yeah and we're
like hey I'm just existing uh [__]
posting on Twitter you know just you
know how it is yeah like two [__] posts
on Twitter you need a lot of trust from
your management yeah yeah
like in order to be like you know super
crazy yeah like you need like people
need to trust you be like it's okay like
you know like she's a decent human human
being in front of them any trouble or
maybe pushing it a little too far
yeah uh do you feel okay do you feel
like you said there's a disparity and
you know you get a lot of stress from
how you feel pressured to act do you
feel like the pressure to be a certain
character or be like I guess like a sort
of like perfect person when you're like
on stage and you know you're presenting
and everything
um yeah do you feel that pressure or are
you just kind of like more chill with it
I I used to feel a lot of pressure but
then again
um I don't know
what was the question again
do I feel pressure with yeah okay so so
you know I'm sorry at least uh with my
experience of like idols from like an
outside perspective there's a lot of
like the image of an idol being like
perfect I guess like the perfect person
do you feel like you have to act like
that as well oh for me
um
I feel like a lot of people actually
expect me to not be perfect okay that's
good with like the way I act but the
problem with me is sometimes people
would think that I'm super outgoing you
know based on my YouTube channel and
everything so whenever they meet me and
they give me like a script for a variety
show they're like can you do this crazy
thing and like not really how much are
you paying so the thing is you know
like it's like an off the party kind of
yeah yeah okay I actually never go to
those because I don't want like people
to socialize I one I don't want to
socialize with two I don't want people
realizing that I'm not as funny as I am
when the camera like you know like I'm a
lot funnier when the cameras are rolling
and like when I'm online right but if
it's just like you know in the private
area and I have to talk to them as a
normal human being like my normal self
is going to come out I feel like at
least in like the more western side
that's people actually like they like it
when they get to meet the other creators
or celebrities whatever yeah you are
like oh it's cool nice to talk to you
and you you're the guy yeah like it
feels like I'm actually meaning yeah
rather than like a personality it kind
of like humanizes that person to a point
where they're not on like a pedestal
anymore and they you know you can they
see them as like more like vulnerable I
guess it's like oh they're just you know
they're just like another human being
like me you know with with faults and
you know because she's just like me for
real she's just like me for real yeah
and then that's that's I'm like a much
bigger appeal as opposed to you know
being this perfect Idol that has no
flaws and I I think that's the like I
think that's an interesting difference
at least from what I've seen from like a
western audience and a Japanese audience
I'm not sure of like the Korean audience
is different at all uh I would assume it
is because every K-pop Idol group I've
seen are [__] perfect in every way
yeah so beautiful
it's crazy yeah
um I forgot what we're talking about uh
yeah going back to Idols so what is like
the normal schedule or like the idle
side of things as opposed to like the
voice acting so what's your what's your
week looking like yeah what's a normal
week it's honestly different every week
and my schedule is also very different
from my members because I'm one of the
few members that are is like actually
pursuing a career in voice acting right
now so it would be like in the morning I
would go to like the anime like the
studio and do some voice acting and then
in the afternoon I would do rehearsals
with my group and just like that every
day and then I'd have like radios I have
like two radios and one
um
live stream yeah yeah so I would film
those and yeah it's basically damn
you're doing everything yeah geez
writing it out Brian is real damn dude
you get much of a say in uh what kind of
projects you take on or is it kind of
like hey this week you're doing this see
you there as long as it's not really out
of my comfort zone you know I'm like I
will do anything especially if it's like
voice acting things because you know
that's what I want to do I build up the
experience right yeah yeah and you know
as a person that's just like starting
out you know everything yeah I don't
really want to like choose and I also
want to be like the type of person that
is able to you know act as anything you
know sure to be flexible right it's
always better you can give me a box and
I will be that box
have you ever done any you know you've
done voice sighting have you ever done
any live action like TV acting never TV
acting like I did one musical yeah I did
a musical foreign
and also
um the I feel like the stage play like
the actor is like the community over
there there is also very different from
the voice acting and the idol industry
it's like you gotta get to know each
other so we can create something amazing
you know yeah it's all communication
based right yeah like my communication
skills is like terrible
terrible it's like I don't have a script
oh yeah how do I communicate so every
single time during rehearsals I would I
already have a script in my head but I
would pretend that I was like looking at
my script so like you know right to make
sure you know be like sorry I'm not
talking to you not because I'm shy but
because I'm focusing on my steps I'm so
sorry
like I I have to act all the time so
that people won't feel uncomfortable
around me the scoop is so important I'm
sorry
I'm sorry guys I'm busy you know this is
very professional it's very awesome that
you've you it's like there's a lot of
social anxiety there yeah you still
haven't let it stop you at any point
you're like I'm gonna do it but I'm just
gonna walk around everything I'm gonna
find a way to make everything work yeah
has there been I guess ever a point
where like I guess your social anxiety
kind of got like the best of you in like
your location yes during the you know
Idols have handshake events oh my gosh
yeah like a nightmare difficulty level
yeah yeah social interaction explain
handshaking events for people that don't
know yeah so handshaking events is like
basically something that comes
with um a CD so you buy a CD and you get
10 seconds with your favorite Idol you
know right which is like okay that's a
crazy trade you say 10 seconds how
strict is the timing is it just like one
handshake well are there people with
like stockings yeah there are
stopwatches and there are people that
are yeah
dudes like not letting go and then like
five guys dragging them I've seen that
but yeah it is literally a dude at the
back like with a stopwatch being like
all right your time starts tell the
story
so yeah so my social anxiety started way
before I became an adult you know as I
said um the reason why I quit figure
skating competitive figure skating was
from my social anxiety so like but I hid
it from my management team like during
the audition too yeah I never told them
so um during the handshake events I was
really thankful for people coming you
know and um I loved them but my brain
and my heart was just like telling me
different things like I would get rashes
on my body and like I couldn't breathe
yeah it was it was you know a lot of
things were happening to me so then I
had to stop and
um but my management team was like
really really nice about it you know um
we decided whether we should inform the
public that I wasn't going to do any
more handshake events because of my
social anxiety or should we just say
she's just not going to do it for
personal reasons and
um at first my manager was like I think
we should hide it because you know just
these things and especially in Japan
it's not you know really a good thing to
say publicly you know like yeah you
might not get many like job
opportunities so she was really worried
for me she was concerned for me but um
the reason why I decided to say that I
had social anxiety and that was the
reason I stopped the handshake event was
to let people know that you know people
with social anxiety can still work you
know like I feel like a lot of people
hide it and that just makes it a lot
harder you know once you just come out
with it it's a lot easier to have people
help you you know like when you're about
to have an anxiety attack if you're
hiding it you're gonna be like oh my God
oh my God oh my God like I can't let it
show but yeah and then they won't be
able to help you out is that right
because I don't know what's happening
like already tell people it can be like
today's not the day
yeah so now it's not the time and like I
feel like
um by me seeing it and you know proving
to people that I can still work in the
entertainment industry while still
having social anxiety I feel like I can
be you know you're just breaking
everything it's like yes you're just
like hey I'm too anxious to do
handshaking events okay you can still
make it work yeah honestly is there
anything that happened during any of
these events that gave you particular
anxiety tools someone was just the idea
of it it was just the idea of it and um
I don't I don't know it was just so many
different people coming to me
yeah it's not like I there was like
somebody that did anything to me like I
really as a person like every single one
of them I loved all of them but it was
just like a thing as a whole yeah yeah I
mean I get it there's a lot of people
and there's a lot of a lot of
interaction in the short amount of time
yeah
um there's a there's a common conception
in Japan that I guess mental health
stuff isn't taken as seriously as it
should and how has your experience been
with that here
came out with it everybody was really
supportive of it that's good it was good
yeah uh the people around me are like
you know like I didn't I didn't really
have an understanding with social
anxiety and I also didn't think like
somebody as outgoing as you on camera
could have social anxiety you know like
I didn't think that was a thing you know
but so I feel like with me saying it you
know well five people got a better
understanding yeah well I mean it's
better than zero yes better than zero
and honestly it's like Master a good
spot yeah
honestly it's like massive props because
you know as you were saying like I feel
Japan is still very much behind when it
comes to like the awareness of mental
health especially compared to like
America right
um and you know I think there's a lot of
jobs they'll be like oh you you have
anxiety no work yeah yeah
definitely you're missing a lot of
people in Japan especially have social
things
are you kidding me the guess
100 yeah yeah so honestly like yeah like
I think it was really Brave of you to to
say that publicly because I'm sure like
you know you are by far not the only one
it's even I reckon like in the idol
industry in itself that you know suffers
from that kind of you know anxiety like
you do right so I think just the fact
that you were even being like you know
what no like I'm just not gonna like run
around the fact like I'm just gonna tell
it how it is and you know it is what it
is kind of deal right so yeah I think
the other thing that was really cool of
you how was the response to all the
announcement I suppose the people that
supported me were also really nice and
you know it just made life so much
easier after yeah yeah because you
stopped you stop needing to feel like
you could you had to pretend yeah just
be like hey I got this uh please
understand if I'm not acting the way
that you think I should act and uh
people move on would you say that you're
you like out of like your fellow members
that you have you deal with the most
social anxiety
um
don't I feel like everybody experiences
things
like but
I feel like not many girls have like
panic attacks as much as I do so I feel
yeah maybe oh they're really good at
hiding it yeah so everyone is a spy yeah
everyone is just fine yeah just lie
again
everyone's lying to each other so I
guess go into your voice I think I saw
that you want to roll in tomachan
recently where you know I think it might
be a first where you voice both the
Japanese character and the English and
the English dub character as well yeah
it was like somebody did it beforehand
but uh it was the first where the
English dub and the Japanese version
were streamed on the same day oh wow
yeah usually there's a gap like several
months you know I must have fun getting
to do the modern good language oh it was
really I didn't I didn't get to do that
with when I was on politics yeah that's
because licensing stuff yeah yeah okay
I'm just like what the [__] FUNimation
you could have just called me bro wait I
would have been down to do it I think it
actually takes way more work to be able
to like how you to do it again yeah yeah
it's like a whole thing yeah did you
have to audition for both the English
dub and the Japanese yeah really they
sent me both the scripts oh wow but you
know how a lot of people don't know that
acting in a different language is so
different yeah just because you can act
in Japanese doesn't mean you can act in
English
so that was my problem I was like I've
never acted in English before Oh okay
because I was like I don't know if I can
do it but I'm gonna send my in my
audition anyway see how they like it and
I somehow got the part though did you
want to voice such in English or was it
something that like your agency was just
like hey you should try dubbing in
English as well that'll be an awesome
experience
um well my agency really didn't say
anything I think it was just a
production team of tomochan is a girl
was like it would be cool if you know
Carol the character that I voiced yeah
was voiced by the same person
that's a flag
which one did you record first was it
the Japanese the Japanese version oh
yeah okay so you got you got like a
Samsung you sounded the English session
like I don't know
all right guys I know the character
ain't my first time I don't know if you
know but I voice this character actually
it was actually really uh easy to do in
English at first they were like we need
two weeks like you need to I we recorded
in Texas they told me I needed to be
there for two weeks because you went all
the way to Texas for yeah
um yeah building and they were like this
is your first time dubbing in English so
you probably need two weeks because you
don't you know know the process but I
finished it in less than four days
you just had like a week off in Texas oh
no so it was just one week I was there
like oh all right so you flew background
was there a reason why they didn't want
to do the job here at Japan remotely I
they said it was because it was my first
time and they wanted okay okay
yeah so how was how was the like I guess
difference between like you know a
Japanese voice acting session versus an
English voice acting session it was so
different first of all like the Japanese
voice acting uh Studio you're there with
majority of the classrooms yeah and well
once covid hit it's more like three to
four people per session but still I was
there with the four main cast members so
we would just you know act it out all
together but in the English dub it was
just me in one Studio it was also really
small too right yeah so and uh the lines
you have to say the lines after this
like three beeping noise
so the Japanese version there's like a
30 minute anime there's an A Part and a
b part and like one is like 15 minutes
and you would test the a part like
without stopping and then you would have
like the real thing right it's just like
two takes you know yeah but the English
is like line by line line by line yeah
yeah so that was yeah because with the
Japanese like with the Japanese side did
you have to worry about matching the
lift flaps or was it just kind of just
say the lines and we'll animate the lip
flaps for you it was like say the lines
but in this timing okay yeah they
normally don't care about lip flops as
much as Japanese yeah yeah I've noticed
sometimes you watch Japanese like anime
and now yeah it just doesn't match at
all there's like a half a second extra
lip flap after they start finish talking
I'm just like what was that yeah it was
English actually very very strict yeah
uh they have to match the syllables yeah
yeah the Japanese lines yeah yeah so
that was interesting super tough because
you're like this sounds unnatural and
they're like well there's nothing
welcome to dubbed anime
they decided to use this word in
Japanese it was 15 songs
did you get the script beforehand for
the English dub as well I got it oh like
a week before but they told me not to
look at it that much because it's going
to change on the spot yeah yeah so I
kind of like flapped through it Japan
being like we didn't know so I I had I
had my first like voice acting
experience in the anime role as well
recently and I just got like Turned Up
on the day I didn't even know it's
normal they normally don't give you the
script before yeah I like I I didn't
know this because I I don't know I turn
off on the day ready to like film like a
vlog right and I'm like so what are we
doing today uh who are my voice acting
because I thought I was just gonna be
like voice acting it's like background
characters or something like that uh and
uh so they get me in the booth uh they
showed me the script and I'm like
Simon names character what the [__] but
I uh I die in this scene
I I I got to do some acting acting and
they're like yeah here's the script
here's your lines I'm like I did not get
any prep for this terrifying whatsoever
were they just like we've seen every
bridge we know you could say come on
don't lie don't light off
this vagrant right here this is the guy
we were in a gacha game and it was we
had like very funny lines and gone just
sounded exactly like I just I just
sounded myself
oh it's gone we immediately recognize
this voice yeah
but yeah it was it was the first song
that I had to like not use my YouTube
voice and I actually had to like I guess
wait what kind of voice did you do oh
yeah I'm so interesting yeah I can't
wait to see this Vlog yeah because like
every time like you know even like with
your older Bridge stuff right yeah I
know in me immediately I'm like oh
that's gone oh it's still me right it's
still definitely me but it's not like
hey guys it's uh I'll make a vlog
I I remember okay so I've seen like the
first draft of my Vlog which is not out
by the way it should be out by the time
this episode's out yeah yeah I voice a
character at Marshall uh oh crap oh hell
yeah yeah yeah voice character in
martial I get like kill I'm one of the
characters that got killed spoilers
um and uh I remember like I I I'm
watching this Vlog back and I do like
okay so we're gonna try the first take
of the line and I didn't even know that
we're just gonna like just jump right
into it yeah didn't really find my voice
at all so I just started reading in my
usual like
voice yeah
uh Vlog I'm just like this sounds so
[__] bad
uh and then they're like okay let's uh
take it like three octaves lower right
uh and I'm like oh I've never done a
voice like this or something like that
and uh
somehow I had like excellent like
directing and I somehow like stumbled
through it and I'm pretty proud of it it
doesn't sound like oh yeah they've done
before a good direction helps a lot yeah
good direction does help a lot so
absolutely I kind of like realized the
uh Power of like good directing did you
did you ever have to with any of your
roles like maybe be asked to do like a
different voice or like a different tone
or anything like that yeah there was a
place I went with uh really high-pitched
voice but they were like no we need an
adult lady and I was like oh no like I
practice all my lines in this like kitty
like yeah yeah suddenly I had to be like
an impact is for that and yeah that was
that was hard right right I went home
crying
[Applause]
I will tell
so how many other like voice acting
roles have you have you been able to get
more now since you've kind of like
opened the door
um yeah slowly but surely right now I'm
doing uh this character called Katarina
from World dye star we have a game
that's a rhythm game that's already out
we haven't downloaded it yet
but yeah but um a lot of the times the
characters I voice are people who speak
another language as well you know
they're actually bilingual and it's
really hard because sometimes people
would be like oh she only got that role
because she can speak English you know
you mad bro I sometimes I need English
yeah we've all seen coconut basket when
they go to America it sounds awful yeah
they should have got English people yeah
sure sure
you know I think that's just so well
it's like oh you were qualified for the
job it's like oh wow like woe is me that
you have a skill that I don't have yeah
exactly wow it's crazy like I used to
get really down about that being like
like I guess you know it's not really my
skill it's just my English but then no
it is a skill yeah but my best friend
was like well you see that girl like she
got in because of her singing that girl
got in because of her appearance like
and you got in because of your English
like what's the difference yeah yeah no
take it with stride yeah
you should be prideful of that yeah hell
yeah yeah you have a skill set that not
a lot of people have especially in Japan
and also you can act on top of that as
well if anything you have a skill that I
think a very large proportion of
Japanese people wish they had yeah you
know which is the just being fluent in
English so it's like you know I I mean I
certainly take that with straw whenever
I'm here you know just being like oh wow
you can speak Japanese and English
that's insane and I'm like and in my
head I'm like yeah I mean it's not I'm
not the only one who has that skill but
then when you think about it it's like
no that is a skill that not everybody
can achieve to you know the certain
level so like yeah I think you should be
very proud of the fact that you can
speak both languages yeah we have
generally no skills anything yeah I'm
taking anything I'm like hey so what
what's the game yeah
I know how to edit a video and speak
English that's uh that's my two skill
sets
yeah you kind of just have to I mean I
think a lot a lot of entertainment
personally I find is you'll never have
the perfect skill set or what you need
to always be the best at everything but
it's like how can I currently take what
I have learn more whilst also applying
the current skills that I have into the
situation to the most useful they can be
yeah so it's always a battle right of
trying to figure that out yeah but
you're in a way more intense environment
yeah this is this we just we just look
at a camera for two hours ago yeah like
that's so hard though because I just
want to announce right now I have never
held a two-hour conversation with
anybody before
like off camera as well off camera as
well like I've never like of course like
you know I've been in a situation where
people are talking for several hours but
I was never part of it you know like I
was just there your managers
like what about the conversations we've
had yeah you're the best buyer yeah
so yeah I was so nervous today because I
was like looking at your podcast and
it's like everything's almost two hours
now I feel even more bad like okay
literally today Sally just like came in
and we're like all right we're starting
guys sit down don't even like we say hi
and yeah yeah and we're like all right
Sun podcast yeah normally we have like
you know 30 40 minute like just kind of
chat off camera to get to know each
other but we just like sit down right
now we're talking yeah it's like I'm so
used to the Japanese like work ex work
environment I thought I was sitting down
to have like rehearsals or something oh
no no like suddenly not a trash days
baby you were like hi everybody I'm like
oh
so we're starting starting were you
laughing or was that just a oh [__] we
uh oh [__] we're starting I thought my
intro was just really weird I'm like I
don't think like it was weird I was
getting self-conscious
as well okay I called the taxi yeah okay
okay no worries so a UK staying for a
little bit longer of course okay I want
to be part of this show forever
oh yeah
did we say this on camera though we
tried to get Sally on three times before
in the podcast
it's taken over a year and every time we
try to schedule her on either her
schedule has been mismatched or our
schedule has been mismatched so we
booked this day in and then like
literally a week ago Conor's like
actually I got a chess tournament no no
if I win I gotta go to La yeah I thought
we're gonna cancel but I was like wait
hold on let me cook I can make this work
so I the moment I learned I gotta do
press stuff gotta leave the country
meanwhile I was like Conor's gonna throw
Connor Connor Connor's definitely gonna
throw one of these chests
and then he just kept playing well I was
like what the [__] first time Connor won
and I was just like damn it
I am I have uh I choke a lot uh when it
matters the most it's my thing
um yeah but super competitive and I
can't like willingly throw something I
just cannot I respect that perform I I
just I there's something in my brain
that won't allow me to not try I will
not be a failure I feel you so hard
because like I said you know in the
aisle group like I don't mind being in
the back you know yeah but thinking
about the rehearsal time you know like
where all the members are there for the
same time like if I'm gonna do it I'd
rather be where like you know yeah of
course yeah I'll be like this dancing's
dumb I don't care and then literally
when I get home I'll be like all right
I'm gonna try my [__] back thank you
no more playing games
foreign
all right this is a real uh trash Chase
first right here I don't think we've
ever switched seats
you know since since Sally is giving us
uh just her first two hour conversation
we we must do we must do uh our first on
trash taste as well you can take my cut
of this episode thank you it's all right
I have the spirit of Suite so uh now
that you have corner seats I gotta ask
uh what's your hottest food take so
we're known on trash case for
shut up so okay so we're known on trash
tasteful having some controversial food
takes do you have any like fruit takes
that you think are like a little bit
weird or
a little weird so why don't we give some
examples from the past okay okay uh for
example uh hates oranges oh like with a
passion like he doesn't just dislike
oranges he despises oranges yeah
you leave yeah I famously said on the
podcast once that all bread tastes the
same
um
it's just different seasonings
for me
do you eat the pizza crust
I don't yes yes oh my God this is this
is one of my favorite moments on trash
days
right now because I mean that's where
you hold it it's a handle okay but but
Americans figured out that oh we we can
add dipping sauce like ranch or
something so that if you have just the
cross left then you can just dip it in
some ranch and you can eat it
deliciously or I should spread in it
yeah pizza's better with different
seasonings
wait wait she's on to something
God damn bro what is your least uh least
favorite American food least favorite I
don't really have like a least favorite
my just like
no no two food
is uh them egg whites uncooked egg
whites uncooked egg whites the texture
is really weird yeah it is a little
plasticky isn't it yeah and it's like
Styrofoam and it's like when I was
really little I thought it would look
like a snail and ever since then I just
couldn't eat it nothing that kind of
looks like a snail and then suddenly you
know yeah because it's like very slimy
isn't it yeah do you eat natto then I
love natto let's go yeah okay finally a
good food
thank God I was about to revoke
that was a test yeah no one in Japan
cares about birds we've seen we've seen
your Gaza sandwiches no one here
you don't [__] with the knock that's
facts how often do you get but uh get to
go back to America I haven't gone back
for four years four years 2019 was the
last year what was it like I guess like
once you the first time you went back to
LA after being here for however many
years you did I forgot like how uh
friendly and unfriendly people in
customer service can be like you know
like it's both a good and bad place
and like they're so polite in America
it's more like what do you want
take it yeah it's like I've like noticed
it's it's okay you know I know why this
is but it's like is this customer does
this customer service position have a
chance to tip if the answer is yes you
have you'll probably have good customer
service if you if the answer is no you
will have the most dog [__] customer
service of all time yeah but like what
what frustrates me more is like you know
the few who are like oh yeah you know
I'm I really want the tips I'm going to
try and be like a nice you know uh
weight or a waitress right but then you
know when you give them like a lower tip
than they expect they turn around being
like what do you mean you didn't give me
18 I filled up your water three times
that's great service and I'm like well
you know yeah it is how it is yeah I
just want to say this this isn't like a
dig at people who work customer service
no you guys are getting [__] over by
your system right yeah yeah it's it's
totally systems yeah uh because yeah
I've noticed that you know when there's
no chance of tip people don't care about
the customer service job because why why
wouldn't they yeah but yeah I mean going
back to America because I just came back
from America
um The Tipping the Tipping culture has
gotten like even more insane so I'm all
for tips right but
you go to like a coffee shop or a
Starbucks and you order a coffee and the
only interaction you get is hey can I
have like a latte please venti or
[__] no it's not venti uh uh it's a
medium size yeah
um and they like turn like turn around
the tablet and the 20 tip is like there
by default
I like it's just like a choice right
it's like 2010 yeah five or no tip yeah
and it's just like I don't want to be an
[__] and say no tip but also I kind
of feel like it's kind of like a dick
move to have it just like default on
like 20 yeah yeah yeah yeah yes that is
true so sure did you find any
experiences when you last went to
America that like changed when you you
had grown up there so when I was there I
would only go out with my parents as a
teenager so I never had to pay for
anything I actually didn't really know
the tip system
that's okay that's not privilege
parent card yeah yeah so I don't I don't
know I don't I almost never really went
out so thank you I can't really
what's something you wish that Japan had
that has that La has
Chen has that La has yeah
um well that Japan should maybe
Implement perhaps
oh gosh I feel like there are many
things but it's like it's okay to say
nothing yeah
oh the no honorifics part no okay go
everything's like so everything's casual
yeah yeah I'm so bad at memorizing memes
you know so but in Japan you can't be
like
a boss in English it could be like you
even if you don't know their name you
could be like hey how are you doing I
never thought about that because it's
the same way in like when I'm in
Thailand and I'm that I'm that
[__] who someone introduces
themselves and I make a mental note to
like not forget that name in the three
sentence I've forgotten it yeah me too
and I I actually I actually do this
thing where every time I meet someone or
I meet like a large group of people yeah
I'm like I always have my phone in my
hand and or in my pocket and what I do
is like I sneakedly I sneakily write the
name down like a general description of
where I met them in a general
description of what they do right and so
when I get their phone number I I kind
of write it down as like it's like Jacob
and then in Brackets it's like uh the
guy I met at this place
and so every time like you know I'm
messaging it because like you know after
you meet so many people you know doing
what we do right yeah there's only so
many subtle some that you can meet where
until you're like wait which subtle
sound was it or like is it a couple song
is it a Suzuki sound like I don't know
like because or because you know you
learn not on a first name basis in a lot
of ways in Japan but on a surname basis
right yeah so it just gets even more
confusing when you're like wait so so
you talked about you know me meeting a
subtles on the other day I'm pretty sure
I met like four of them last week and I
don't remember which one was which you
know God I had a moment from my
nightmares and the recent trip I had
which is related to this yeah um so I
the reason I flew back to America was to
go to my wife's family reunion uh so
I've met her family a bunch of times but
also she has a massive family like it's
a big Midwestern family so many cousins
so many uncles uh and I remember like
meeting like one of her cousins right
and I'll be honest she has a lot of
cousins I don't remember all of their
names I know it's I know like there's
like a pool of names uh I don't know
he's like one of those names you know
what I mean it's either like a uh Tommy
or a Ryan or a Tim or something it's
like in the pool of like names so I go
in and I've met him like a few times
before uh shake his hand and he goes hey
God nice to see you again I'm like Hey
man nice to meet you dead ass he like
shakes my hand looks me in the eye and
he goes what's my name
blue screened as a human I'm like
um and then he's like ah don't worry man
don't worry about it it's Ryan and I I
realize now why he did that what if he
was like just kidding it's Tommy I told
you I realized because uh we had we had
like a party afterwards uh and uh some
some other like friends came over and uh
he was there uh and when they met Ryan
they're like oh hey Ryan I remember it
this time I actually remember it this
time so I think he says that to everyone
so nobody forgets his name and it
[__] worked because that like I think
he's instilled PTSD into me I will never
now never forget his name when I see him
I mean it's it's a bit of a double-edged
sword because now everyone who is
associated with Ryan knows who Ryan is
but at the same time I feel a lot of
people are gonna be like what an [__]
I can't believe you just put me on the
spotlight I mean I mean yeah uh yeah
that's like I that's the thing you like
you see in your nightmare they actually
happened I'm like oh no oh no but
luckily luckily we go we got like the
good ending that's good uh just gonna
put me through like personal trauma
God damn yeah my manager calls everybody
sends it
yeah even like in like an honorful way
and also like a frankly being like like
hey boss or like yeah hey boss you know
she uses it for everybody she uses it
for me too I'm like you don't know my
name
[Laughter]
I do the equivalent in English where I
just call everyone dude like it doesn't
matter like it doesn't matter like how
many times I've met you what gender you
are what age you are like I'll call a 90
year old grandma dude like I'm just like
just so I can get out of the situation
and be like I apologize I don't remember
your name but I want to be friendly with
you so I'll just throw it I'll start
it's the magical word to just be like oh
yeah no he's cool with me yeah does he
know my name though I don't know
probably not have you ever met someone
and you're like uh you know they they
refer to you as like dude or someone or
you like you just know that they do not
know your name oh yeah oh definitely
yeah and I don't like I don't want to be
an [__] about it but because I've
been in that situation so many times but
sometimes there's a look in their eye
you know where there's like the slight
like Panic where I'm like I hope he
doesn't I'm I'm actually really
sympathetic for people who do that
because I'm exactly the same right so
like you know any chance I can get like
I'll maybe like throw in my name or like
Clues to my name like yeah in the
conversation do that as well you know
like sometimes like I'd be telling a
story about like you know an anecdote
about something that happened to me and
then I'll switch to like third person
being like Joey you [__] up to be like
quickly grab it yeah I said my name and
remember it and like and like you see
like the light wall pops up yeah and
they're like oh that's his name
yeah so that's like a little thing I
like to do because you know I get it I
wish people did that more for me
sometimes I do like the alley-oop yeah
okay so uh so there's been times when I
know my wife can't remember her name uh
and I do like the alley-oop I just like
call to them or something like
yo yo Rob how are you doing and you know
I I know I know Sydney's listening at
that point so you know if sometimes
sometimes people do that to me as well
and it's just like all right everyone
gets it yeah but okay to be fair you
have a very memorable name
I've met a lot of Joey's in my life you
are the only one and only God I have met
in my life my biggest problem is making
sure people actually can pronounce my
name once they get the pronunciation
then most of the time they remember it
yeah sure do you have a technique of
like when you you're in the industry and
you don't know someone's name do you use
the Sensei technique or I run past them
as fast as I could as if I'm in a hurry
like I'm like checking my phone like
let's get someone else because I don't
want to be rude so um I usually like
pretend I'm only running because I'm
late to something yeah I would talk to
you if I had the time but I can't I'm
sorry
kind of personal question people really
uh social anxiety uh have you ever
pretended to be on the phone yes okay
you do that as well and also a very life
hack if you're left with somebody that
you you feel really uncomfortable with
or like you're really nervous I put my
timer for like two minutes and then I
like leave it on the table and then it
rings and I'm like oh I got a phone call
I gotta go I'm just I gotta go
[Laughter]
that's so good I gotta take this
dude like I'm like giving all these like
tips and tricks to like get out of the
situation sounds just like I'm a [__]
dick I'm not even I'm not even in this
right now I'm just gonna go I'm like
that's so funny well I guess um yeah
like you know none of them like what
what what's your guys's uh next steps
like what do you have going up we have a
second album coming out in November 22nd
oh yeah and we have an online talk event
as well uh yeah so if you guys are
interested please come oh yeah bye yeah
hell yeah do you have anything else you
want I mean you've seen it seems like
you've done so much already is there
anything else you want to do or like a
role in voice acting or like a project
that you like dream of getting oh
oh gosh
would you just explode at that point I
mean there would have to be like an
ambulance there every week
to be fair yeah so tell me are there any
like uh future events we can see you at
or you fans can see you at
um I'm actually going to be the emcee
for aof
2023.00
public speaking
yeah anyplex on Lane Fest 2023 it's
happening on September 9th
99. now I won't ever forget it
yeah
from 8 P.M
PDT yes PDT
it looks like you look like someone just
like is pointing a gun
September 9th yes
we're going to be announcing a lot of
new antiplex titles yeah a lot of new
information link twice if you are okay
yeah okay if I'm okay okay
blink twice if you're not okay
[Laughter]
and uh you know uh with that event as
well I think uh there might be even like
a little secret like trash taste
appearance maybe I don't know you know
how long the event's gonna be last year
was like five hours this is the fourth
time this year I've been the MC for four
consecutive years so you're gonna be
there is that all scripted or do you get
to like
um
I got to go off script a little bit but
yeah yeah really on time and we have a
lot of artists coming too awesome yeah
right on yes wish you the best of luck
yeah the best of luck with I hope your
contact lenses I will go in my glasses
and they're still gonna fall off and
crack annoying me
uh yeah thank you very much for coming
onto the show we appreciate you again
you're welcome thank you for staying the
entire two hours and not running off
wouldn't it be fun if she's like
actually guys I got a phone call sorry
oh that's my alarm gotta go
hey look at all these patrons on screen
right now do you see all the patrons
flying up on screen Sally point point to
your favorite Patron right just point to
anyone's point it is Lucky Bastard if
you got pointed to God damn but hey if
you want to support us uh and uh like
the show enough then head on over to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
Twitter send us to memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face let's
toss on Spotify is there any uh socials
you want to shout out
um I do Twitter I do Instagram Tech talk
is like I mean I'm on it but like I just
do English Daily Business English
lessons if you want to see some is it
actual like daily English lessons no
it's more like it's like it's always
like five I gotta kill myself
but yeah and I also have a YouTube
channel so yeah exactly is all down in
the description but uh hopefully you
guys enjoyed this episode of trash taste
and we will see you all next week
thank you
[Music]